استخبارات سيول تكشف حقائق جديده عن حياه
زعيم كوريا الشماليه الذي لطالما اخفاها
عن وسائل الاعلام واعين شعبه ايضا جدل
كبير سببه هذه المره اطفال كيم جونغ اون
صاحب الاستعراضات النوويه الاستخبارات
كشفت عن عدد ابناء الزعيم ثلاثه اولاد
البكر ذكر والثانيه انثى والثالث لم يحدد
اوسطهم ابنته كيم جو اي التي ظهرت معه في
اكثر من مناسبه اخرها عندما تم اختبار
الصواريخ الباليستيه العابره للقارات وهي
خطوه تنذر باحتمال انتقال الزعامه لجيل
رابع من عائلتك
وفقا للمشرعين الذين اطلعتهم المخابرات
الوطنيه الكوريه الجنوبيه على المعلومات
فان البنت الثانيه التي باتت رفيقه والدها
لم يتم رصد اسمها في ايه مؤسسه تعليميه
وانها تت تعليمها من المنزل وصدر مرسوم
بمنع المواطنين من تسميه اسمها ومن له
اسمها قبل ولادتها عليه ان يغيره لكن
اطفالكم الاول والثالثه لم يروا علنا ابدا
وليس هناك اي دليل مفصل عنهم سوى ان اول
طفل له ولد في عام 2010 وسط انباء انه
يعاني من مشاكل جسديه وعقليه لم يتم
تاكيدها بسبب الرقابه الصارمه والمعلومه
الوحيده ان الطفل الثالث ولد في فبراير
2017 وعمره الان ست سنوات تقريبا وفق
مراقبين كوريا الشماليه تعتبر دوله مغلقه
بشكل كبير عن البلدان الاخرى ومن الصعب
التحقق من المعلومات المتعلقه بمجتمعها
وحكومتها وخاصه عن الرئيس وعائلته